celui qui fait pas du tout attention à
son look c'est thierry moreau je suis en
chine ouais mais n'en faites pas du tout
at on fait une petite chenille ça mais
toujours d'aider manteau trop grand pour
lui ça l'équipe c'est pas sa faute
non mes shoes aujourd'hui c'est en fait
voir les chaussures aujourd'hui s'il
vous plaît pas ce que l'on va faire sa
randonnée a wave dégueulasse et bien
voilà à temps des fêtes voilà les
chaussures on attendait l'or et c'est
bon c'est bon vous êtes en train de vous
lever mettez-vous la voilà c'est le swag
dames c'est le seul
j'espère les mouches de toujours
regarder notre hymne est trop grand ces
chaussures elles sont dégueulasses on
dirait qu'ils les acheter chez legg
tabasse arrêter avec ça du loup propose
que au parlant de douala ii de cette
émission vous fassiez passé chaque
chroniqueur et vous nous dire ce que
vous pensez de son look d'accord et vous
venez là alors thierry moreau déjà dit
le spécialiste
oui ici qu'est-ce qui se passe
mettez-vous la lumière entrer dans la
lumière comme un insecte vous renvoie la
chaussure et pardon jva chose sur un
gars jean ça fait un peu vient vieux 500
et trolard jambes à l'arrière alors tu
n'y connais rien parce que c'est ça
c'est une tenue de travail le dgi au
départ on ne répond pas mathieu rim là
et moi ça y'a pas de fès a fait une
couche c'est ridicule
la chemise on est honnête et la chemise
voilà s'agit pas responsables finissent
pas pour moi vous êtes responsable voilà
la lâche plus sa patte rôle ah ben ça
parce que l'on peut centrer battus chez
une question posée pour soi rien lui va
les bonnes questions
aujourd'hui ces mêmes questions n'ont
alors pas après il y là il est bien
physiquement mais déjà parce que comme
il fait pas attention à son corps il
manque des poules dubaï mais ça montre
des poules ça manque un peu de jambes ça
manque un peu de faits ça manque un peu
de tout donc après les vêtements bon
bassam encore cette année bien sam en
valeur
l'avocate me détendre
non il est beau il est beau il est très
bon dans l'échangé vu il est beau il me
fait chier je l'emmène alors attendez ni
déjà parlé déjà déjà les séries venez
voir les ja c'est le seul mec il a des
chaussures on dirait des paninis sérieux
konami souplesse opulence al ahly dans
un pavillon en fait il a d'abord jamais
là dans l'es9 le gard non merci d'être
là dans ma vie j'ai jamais vu un jean
pareil il est droit 16 octobre il est 3
l'argent bas et puis tu ne montres
ushuaïa même là tu vois bien regardez
bien fondu sous charles pas possible ça
quand même franchement ça va être serré
cheveux est-ce qu'on peut pas l'habiller
comme matthieu delormeau voilà non pour
dépasser pour voir ce que ça donne
anaky et les séries jeanne a mobilisé sa
les changements
je suis allé au sein des commentaires
et allez vous asseoir et après pendant
la pub vous échangez des vêtements
bon je suis allé là j'ai l'impression de
faire c'est mon choix pour le look et un
julien julien changerait bien que la
tête de ma mère
toutes les personnes autour de cette
table enfin certaines personnes de se
changer donc on a donné à mathieu les
affaires de gilles jean mathieu et
julien combes et a voulu faire le malin
moi je songerai avec nadège et julien
elle a pas compris on est plus sur tf1
on dit quelque chose on sait direct
après donc voila et donc julliard a
regretté un petit peu trop tard eh bien
je voudrais qu'on va les accueillir a
pas un s'il vous plaît pour qu'on voit
bien laissez vous paie mailing donc
j'aimerais pas qu'on les voit donc on va
accueillir la première bas seules qu'on
va accueillir
je pense que c'est nadège julien combes
et nadège aussi la combine
ça lui va bien
alors vous savez pas vous avez connu à
faire un strip tease à l'injonction
d'accord nom génial jean-luc suis
d'accord strip tease jamais sans rigoler
on veut dire et d'autres conseillers bnp
ou au crédit lyonnais lcl appel à la
banque c'est vrai c'est vrai crédit
agricole ou encore crédit mutuel voilà
la mer entre ils ont la même taille donc
c'est plutôt encourageant mais tant
qu'on la leur
on va accueillir maintenant matthieu
delormeau gilles verdez
parce que pour moi
le dieu des fous sans y laisser la
chiraquie khemiri la caisse qui l'a
alors ils content mais je ne veux pas
quoi dire mais ils montrent très bon il
est pas mal quand même non
vous me laissez jamais son look petites
jambes cigarettes avec les ting et ses
hommes c'est bien parce qu'il ya les
copains m'ont dit que j'avais pas été
gentil avec thierry dont je lui ai
présenté mes excuses qu'il n'y avait
aucune méchanceté de ma part vous
attirez prochain vous venez mais il est
bon de ouf il le sait vraiment épatant
merci attention aux accueillir tout de
suite on va accueillir aller moi je
pense qu'il faut accueillir gilles
verdez gervais jean matthieu delormeau
vous allez voir le beau gosse
franchement j'avais sur twitter est ce
que vous ne trouvez pas 100 fois mieux
comme ça mais rien à voir l'un qui vous
dit avec moi j là y'a moyen de me louis
way n'est pas le même
je me plais 2
bien que
cahill très sexy magnifique et à laisser
comme ça tu dois aller voir ça nous
regarde
est ce qu'elle peut tweets et si ça lui
plaît ou pas tout ohlala slashtags
atouts pour faite chez covidien
on va tous se mobilisent pour toi tous
nous disent que du bon vous parlez
maintenant ou taisez vous à tous jeunes
passaient lui fait un beau un beau cul
en plus
non mais c'est surtout parce qu'il a
vécu les glaces non justement
comme quoi voilà j bien vous êtes super
bowl sur la première on s'est regardés
même isabelle âgés tous magnifiques
comme ça c'est vrai que vous laissez
jamais mais vous habiller comme sarah
tôt si mais c'est trop facile après faut
se mettre d handicap dans la vie
il faut semer des handicaps mais quand
on parle pas tous les apu dr c'est pas
la peine de rajouter non plus c'est vrai
que vous non là vraiment je vous jure
gilles vous avez un look incroyable
allez on va cueillir maintenant celui
qui doit être très réussi j'espère qu'il
avait des chaussures aussi ah ben non
non j'ai gardé les miennes ça nous
arrange pas vu la poubelle
j'ai refusé j'ai on a tout changé
c'est vrai il ya qu un truc que j'ai
refusé ces deux maîtres slip de nadège
nuit
en tout cas je vous le dis alors jeune
carrière d'acteur qui sont très réussis
c'est julien et gilles mais en fait je
vous le dis je trouve que les quatre ça
vous va beaucoup mieux comme ça je pense
pour les trois zones pour moi je sais
pas s'ils jouent bien dedans mais non
julien parce que vous les lunettes la
barbe et la robe ça casse ça casse le
rythme séquentiel
c'est ce qu'il fallait c'est ce qu'il
fallait jouer